on Sunday the 4th of September 2022 more
than 70 000 people have demonstrated in
Prague in favor of Russia you heard that
right these 70 000 people were calling
for their country the Czech Republic to
get into Russia and stop sanctioning it
in exchange for the return of cheap
natural gas think about it the Czechs
were invaded by the Russians for decades
I mean come on they know what it means
to be a colony of Russia if this is what
is happening in the Czech Republic
imagine the situation in other European
countries that have not experienced
Russian occupation in France they have
also had similar protests and in Spain
where Ukraine is quite far away some
voices seem to be asking for something
similar pay attention to what the former
vice president of Spain Pablo Inglesias
is
but why does some people want to give in
to Russia the answer is simple Europe
seems to be heading for a gas mageddon
if you remember a few weeks ago we
released a video here on visualpolitik
where we talked about the natural gas
crisis
on the 1st of September Russia announced
that it was cutting off all gas passing
through the nordstream pipeline not 20
not 10 the total Supply zero percent of
Russian gas arriving in Germany while it
is true that some Russian gas is still
arriving through Ukraine and turkey we
were talking about a much smaller Supply
the fact is that since the start of the
war in Ukraine Moscow has been
regressively reducing gas supplies to
Europe as a means of applying pressure
Putin is using energy as a weapon by
cutting Supply and manipulating our
energy markets he will fail Europe will
prevail Ursula V on the lion in other
words recession in Europe is almost
inevitable and so is gas rationing let's
put it plainly we are in an energy war
with Russia instead of sending all
Europeans to a Siberian Gulag Putin has
sent a little bit of Serbia to all of
their homes this also affects
electricity we are all seeing how
electricity bills are skyrocketing and
some we are talking about paying up to
two three or even four times more than
what we were paying before and as you
can imagine many are panicking about
what could be the coldest and most
expensive winter of Our Lives a real
gasmageddon
and all while this is going on Russia
seems to be resisting the impact of the
sanctions or at least that's how it
appears or rather that's what the
Kremlin insists on showing for example
while Europe is racking its brains to
see how to respond to the gas crisis
Putin has just inaugurated one of the
largest gas pipelines in Europe the
moscow's Sun and Putin keeps assuring
that Russia has not lost and will not
lose anything
[Music]
so the Temptation for many is what if we
give up obviously this question is out
of the question if Europe surrenders to
Putin there would be nothing to stop him
from invading other countries in the
future but not only that what if I told
you that the price to be paid would not
be that high to put it another way do we
actually have a problem here yes but
much less than gasmageddon that many
people imagine for example take a look
at this graph
[Music]
what you can see here are the Dutch ttf
gas Futures the gas price Benchmark if
you notice the gas price Peak came on
August 26th that is four days before the
total cutoff of Russian gas after the
announcement of the nordstream shutdown
prices have not only not risen but have
actually continued to fall of course gas
is still extremely expensive it
currently costs six times more than it
did a year ago now the fact that Putin's
news has not pushed gas prices even
higher is very telling still not
surprised well here comes another fact
[Applause]
[Music]
gas deposits at 80 by the first of
November well that Target was already
exceeded at the beginning of September
at the time of making this video Europe
had filled 85.6 of its gas reserves in
other words with hardly any Russian gas
Europe already has enough reserves to
last until Christmas what's more with
energy saving measures these reserves
could last even longer yes it is true
this winter will be lights out for the
Eiffel Tower and so for many other other
iconic monuments at night it's not going
to be an easy winter and some countries
may even have to establish some sign of
rationing or limitations but rest
assured that gasmageddon can be avoided
the question now is how where is Europe
getting the natural gas to replace
Russian gas how are the astronomical
electricity price hikes going to be
solved and more importantly why do we
say that Russia is much worse off than
it seems today we're going to answer all
of these questions but first let's look
at some history
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the biggest criticisms of
capitalism is that it benefits the rich
right well there are times when that is
true and this is one of them no do you
know exactly who the rich are in this
story it's the European Union let me
spell it out clearly Europe has money
and since Europe has money it's done in
Uncle Scrooge McDuck and has taken over
almost the entire gas Market at the
stroke of a pen we saw it here in a
previous video of this series the gas
market in 2022 looks like a Turkish
Bazaar uh how much is Pakistan paying
you for that shipload of gas you know
what it doesn't matter I don't care I'll
pay you more what's the conclusion then
as you can see in this graph the price
of gas rules throughout the summer
that's because Europe was willing to pay
a fortune for all those liquefied
natural gas tankers to divert their
route to European Shores thanks to all
this natural gas reserves have been
filled in record time despite Russia all
of this provides a Lifeline that may
last until Christmas but not only that
the chart we are comparing the one which
you have already seen in other media are
the spot prices that is the prices of
gas Futures with immediate expiration
now then check out this other chart
[Music]
here you can see the gas Futures in the
long term for example if we buy a Dutch
gas future with a maturity date of 2026
it costs us almost the same as it did
before the war well what this means is
that gas investors who have much more
information than the average person
expect gas prices to go down and why may
you ask because little by little New
Alternatives to Russian gas are
appearing for example Norway is
exploiting gas at record levels so
without a doubt the new super gas
supplier is the United States we've
already talked about this before on
visualpolitik Uncle Sam is exporting
more gas to Europe than ever before but
I know what you're thinking if you're a
long time follower of visualpolitik you
already know that almost all of this new
gas coming to Europe is not coming
through Pipelines
[Music]
it does so via liquefied natural gas or
LNG and this gas has one very big
problem to buy LNG you need to have a
regasification plant in your country in
other words the gas comes out of the
field and gets turned into a liquid
thanks to this it can be transported by
ship but once it arrives at its
destination it needs to be converted
back into a gas again right this
requires so-called regasification plants
well until now Europe had very few such
plants Germany for example does not have
any the gas came through pipelines which
was much cheaper almost all the
regasification plants were in Spain but
Spain is an energy island is barely
connected with the rest of the continent
so the question is how is it possible
that Europe can suddenly buy so much LNG
overnight the answer lies again in
capitalism
foreign
because Europe is wealthy and can put
money on the table Miracle Solutions
appear that are previously Unthinkable
something similar to what happened with
the covet vaccine and believe me there
is a lot of money on the table right now
check this out Germany earmarks 3
billion euros for floating LNG terminals
I present to you a new Prodigy of
Technology floating natural gas
regasification terminals also known as
fsrus well this is much faster and much
much cheaper an fsru costs between 400
and 500 million dollars it takes about
three years to build each one but it can
be done even faster and cheaper how by
converting methane tankers into floating
terminals this can be done in fact it's
actually a very fast process it can be
taken between 18 months and costs
between 100 million and 150 million
dollars and because they are floating
terminals they can be moved from one
place to another in a matter of months
to give you an idea right now there are
48 floating terminals in the world and
558 LNG tankers that is ships carrying
liquefied natural gas in 2021 Europe had
only four floating terminals but that is
changing fast
if you remember natural gas is measured
in bcms that is billions of cubic meters
of gas well at the time of making this
video the Netherlands already has two
floating terminals that can process 14
new bcms the Czech Republic which is
landlocked by the way has already
contracted three bcms from one of these
terminals but the case of Germany is
even more impressive Germany has already
secured six floating plants three of
them are going to be ready for operation
by Christmas and now let's do a little
maths here last year Germany bought 45
to 50 bcms of natural gas from Russia
well with the regasification capacity
they have already contracted Germany
will be able to import between 40 and 45
bcms of natural gas
[Music]
in other words by next winter Germany
will be able to do without almost all
Russian gas at least as far as the
receiving infrastructure is concerned so
now the race is on to find suppliers but
as we have told you the good news for
Europe is that the old continent has
money obviously the rising cost of
Supply will affect the economy but not
as much as a full gas mageddon would but
this is not the only big news at the
time of making this video Germany and
Spain are trying to boost the
construction of a gas pipeline that
would connect Spain with the rest of
Europe
there is an alternative to Russian gas
that is if France stops blocking the
pipeline by the way but I know what many
of you are thinking okay yes Checkmate
Russia and whatever you want but who's
paying my electricity bill I can't make
ends meet as it is is there a solution
for this well we're gonna find that out
now
[Music]
avoiding gasmageddon
[Music]
who's rich and has money to pay for gas
however not all Europeans are rich
enough to pay the Diabolical prices of
the latest energy bills and this is
where an interesting question comes in
the Czech Republic is one of the
countries where the price of electricity
is rising the most however the Czechs
have a nuclear power plant which account
for 18 of their mix isn't nuclear
supposed to be cheap energy how is it
possible that this does not lower the
electricity bill this is where our
friend the marginal price system comes
in that is the price of electricity is
set by the most expensive Source you see
every country has a company usually
state owned or with close ties to the
state that manages the national electric
grid these entities are the ones that
buy the energy from the nuclear power
plant solar Farms gas plants and they
sell it to the electricity companies
every day that company conducts an
auction to cover all the electricity
demand of that day for example let's
imagine that Spain expects to consume 30
000 megawatts of energy today open the
auction and the cheapest sources such as
nuclear coming remember that nuclear
plants operate continuously so
regardless of the price they are going
to supply electricity their price is
zero Euros they are going to sell no
matter what then come green energies
which are more expensive than cool Hydro
electric Etc and finally we come to
gasoline
[Music]
the price of gas is skyrocketing gas
plants cannot sail below a certain
amount let's say 190 Euros per megawatt
hour well the price per megawatt for
that day would be 190 Euros that is the
marginal pricing system and it's been
working very well for years however it
was not designed for war conditions so
what is happening now well the classic
energy producers nuclear green Etc are
making extraordinary profits so who are
the big losers exactly the consumers and
the energy companies that buy the gas in
the international market think about it
when for example IBO drula buys energy
from the Spanish power grid operator it
is paying prohibitive prices but in many
cases consumers pay flat rates for
electricity think about it let's use the
UK for an example right when British gas
buys energy from the UK as power grid
operator the National Grid it is paying
prohibitive prices but in many cases
consumers pay flat rates for electricity
in other words there are not only
consumers who cannot make ends meet
there are also many electricity
companies across Europe that are sharply
reducing their benefits or even on the
verge of bankruptcy and that explains
news like this German Energy company
Juniper asks for bailout so how can all
this be solved
the debate is on the table right now
some countries want to intervene in the
pricing system instead of setting prices
by auction it would be set by the state
this would disrupt the energy market and
break legal certainty in the long term
it would create nothing but problems
what other solution can be applied then
very easy those who have the most should
pay the most and who are they exactly
the energy producers we are talking
about imposing attacks on the
extraordinary profits being earned by
the owners of nuclear plants solar
farmed windmills Etc these taxes would
be used to pay for two things possible
bailouts for electricity companies and
subsidies for consumers who are drowning
in electricity bills on the other hand
other countries such as Germany are
taking other types of drastic solutions
to avoid further distortions Solutions
like this one Germany sees his Russian
oil firm rosneft's refineries the ones
that are on German soil conclusion the
situation is changing day by day but
there are several ways to avoid
gasmageddon yes it is true this winter
we are going to see cities half turned
off the Sagrada Familia in Barcelona
will not turn on its lights at night and
we're all going to be paying Hefty bills
but there will be gas in Winter and
there is money to give Aid to avoid
social problems and now a curious fact
do you remember that Ferris wheel that
Putin had inaugurated in Moscow well it
closed due to technical problems just a
day after its opening and this is a very
symbolic figure of what is happening in
Russia
[Music]
as we've already covered on our sister
Channel visual economic the strength of
the Russian Ruble is the only good
indicator they have but keep two things
in mind one the gas and oil that Russia
sold to Europe accounted for 45 of all
of its exports in other words at the
moment Russia has a hole in its Public
Accounts as gigantic as the electricity
bills that Europeans are currently
paying two the cost of the war at the
moment the Kremlin has announced a
partial military mobilization that is to
force many young Russians to go to war
this would not only have a political
cost but also an economic cost you have
to train harm and feed hundreds and
thousands of soldiers meanwhile Putin
has already met with Xi Jinping hoping
for support from China which is not
forthcoming China remains on the side
Lanes in the Ukraine war in fact the
Kremlin is so desperate to get
ammunition and weaponry from abroad that
it may be buying from North Korea it's
my awesome t-shirt for the moment
Beijing support for Moscow remains at
the level of lip service and India is
already beginning to pressure Russia to
end the war in other words Putin is
increasingly in trouble he has lost all
his bargaining chips in Europe he has
lost his main source of income and he's
losing the war but we'll talk about that
in more more detail in future videos for
now the question is over to you do you
think the Russian economy is going to
collapse do you think these measures
will be enough for Europe to avoid gas
again this winter or maybe we'll see new
gas price hikes you can leave me your
answer in the comments below and as
always don't forget that here on
visualpolitik we release new videos
every week subscribe to this Channel and
hit the little bell button down there so
you don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it so we know all
the best and I'll see you next time
[Music]